ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen als
vor 300 und einem Tag der Krieg in der
Ukraine begann da dachten viele das geht
schnell das sagt manche Experten manche
Philosophen wir wissen es sollte anders
kommen in der Ukraine selbst tobt nach
wie vor ein heißer Krieg und zwischen
Moskau und Washington ein kalter heute
ist ein vielschichtiger Tag zum einen
Präsident selenski ist aus der Ukraine
erstmals hinausgefahren geflogen er ist
in Washington wir sehen gleich Bilder
live von seiner Ankunft dort wir
vorfährt im Weißen Haus es ist das erste
Mal dass er sein Land verlassen hat seit
Ausbruch des Krieges er ist nicht nach
Brüssel gereist nicht nach Paris nicht
nach London
erst recht nicht nach Berlin sondern
eben nach Washington auch das sagt ja
etwas aus es geht um ein waffenpaket im
Wert von fast zwei Milliarden US-Dollar
darunter
auch das Patriot Abwehrsystem wie gesagt
wir sehen hier schon erste Bilder wir in
Washington ankam wir schauen gleich live
dahin spreche mit unseren
Korrespondenten noch ein Hinweis zuvor
denn es gab heute noch mehr auch
Präsident Putin hat sich geäußert in
Moskau bei der Sitzung des russischen
Verteidigungsministeriums er betonte
einmal mehr die siegessicherheit seines
Landes und gab auch einen Einblick in
das was Russland vorhat in der Ukraine
und schließlich mit mediaf das ist die
rechte Hand Putins der war heute in
China bei Staatschef hi da werden heute
also wirklich große Weichen gestellt die
wahrscheinlich maßgeblich sein während
für den Verlauf dieses Krieges all das
wollen wir thematisieren mit unseren
Korrespondenten mit Militärexperten und
mit euch ihr seid wie immer eingeladen
teilzunehmen und teil zu haben ihr könnt
eure Meinung und Fragen stellen ich bin
lese die dann gerne vor und bringen sie
mit ein in Gespräche im Chat oder unter
die jetzt hier eingeblendete adresse.de
schauen wir zu Beginn nach Washington
ich habe es gerade schon gesagt der
ukrainische Präsident selenski ist vor
Ort er ist angekommen in wenigen Minuten
soll es ein shakehand geben am Weißen
Haus mit Präsident beiden und vor Ort
ist unser korresponent MRT wir sind
hallo Elmar
ich habe es gerade schon gesagt das ist
ein besonderes
er ist nicht nach Brüssel gefahren oder
nach Berlin London sondern eben in
Washington das hat gute Gründe welche
ja ich glaube Vlado mir selensky weiß
dass es hier eigentlich um vieles
vielleicht sogar alles geht denn die
Unterstützung der USA militärisch
gesehen und auch finanziell ist die
allerwichtigste für die Ukraine und so
lang die USA dicht an der Seite von der
Regierung in Kiew stehen so lange hat
die Ukraine eben auch eine Chance
gegenzuhalten vielleicht sogar eine
bessere Position zu erreichen um auch
irgendwann mal in Verhandlungen zu gehen
aber man ist sich hier im Weißen Haus
sehr einig es wird kein Drängeln es wird
keine Ansporn es wird auch keinen
anpieksen geben so hat uns das ein enger
Berater von Joe Biden gesagt dass man
den Präsidenten der Ukraine dazu bewegen
wollte jetzt Verhandlungen anzustreben
weil man sieht kein Signal aus Moskau
dass Putin in irgendeiner Form von
seinen Maximalforderungen abrückt
selenski ist vor etwas mehr als einer
Stunde hier hinter uns angekommen mit
seiner Kolonne er ist im Gästehaus des
der US-Regierung dem sogenannten
Lehrhaus schräg gegenüber vom weißen
Haus wird eben in wenigen Minuten
wahrscheinlich dann hinten am südrasen
auf der Rückseite des Weißen Hauses von
Präsident beiden begrüßt werden genau
diese Bilder sehen wir jetzt auch gerade
und ich kommentiere das mal live weil du
sozusagen auf der anderen Seite stehst
bis zwei dichter dran aber ich habe die
Bilder hier vor Ort im Moment sehen wir
das Livebild dass die Limousine vorfährt
dort am südrasen und jetzt das
vorgeordnet wird und
es steigt aus noch ist es dunkel
offenbar nicht auf dieser Seite sondern
auf der anderen wir werden gleich sehen
wenn der Wagen fortgefahren ist ich
glaube schon die First Lady gesehen zu
haben vorhin und jetzt sehen wir die
drei der Präsident die First Lady und
selenski vor Ort das ist Elmar wir
können das glaube ich jetzt live
kommentieren
beiden legt die Hand auf die Schulter
von silensky das ist ein Bild mit viel
Symbolik wie wird das in den USA gesehen
bei beiden wir leben zeigen dass er sich
das vladomir selenski sich absolut auf
diesen Mann im Weißen Haus verlassen
kann wir wissen ja alle durch die Wahlen
die Zwischenwahlen zum Kongress dass die
Mehrheit im Repräsentantenhaus
gewechselt hat ab Januar sind die
Republikaner in der Führung im
Repräsentantenhaus und die haben ja
schon angekündigt dass es schwieriger
werden wird Milliarden Summen für die
Ukraine zu mobilisieren haben sie
Einspruch angedeutet und umso wichtiger
ist jetzt dieses Signal ich glaube Joe
Biden will nicht nur gleich Zusagen das
wird der öffentlich machen dass noch mal
zwei Milliarden direkt an die Ukraine
jetzt gehen in den nächsten Tagen
darunter auch das Patriots
Flugabwehrsystem was sehr wichtig zum
Schutz von Kiew oder anderer Städte ist
sondern dass man eben auch ein neues
Paket durch den amerikanischen Kongress
bringen will noch vor der Jahresende das
heißt mit den alten Mehrheiten
hoffentlich auch so denkt man den Weißen
Haus mit der Unterstützung einiger
Republikaner da geht es um 45 Milliarden
Dollar und das würde zeigen dass für die
nächsten Monate die Militärhilfe die
finanzielle Hilfe die Sozialhilfe auch
für die Menschen in der Ukraine
gewährleistet bleibt egal ob die
Mehrheit sich im Repräsentantenhaus
verändert hat das ist gerade schon
genannt Wasser bekommt allen voran eben
die Patrick Raketen das ist ein
Abwehrsystem das bekommt sie lensident
nicht
ja es gibt im Grunde genommen keine
Angriffswaffen wo man auf allergrößte
Entfernung Ziele treffen könnte also
über mehrere hundert Kilometer
möglicherweise auch eben noch keine
Kampfjets aber bei Panzern sind die USA
absolut der Meinung müsste die Ukraine
auch Panzer haben können weil man damit
Gelände Gewinne erzielen kann solange
sichergestellt ist dass man nicht auf
russisches Gebiet fährt die Annektion
der Krim aber auch die Annektion der
Ostgebiete der Ukraine wird nicht
anerkannt vom weißen Haus insofern ist
das ukrainisches Gebiet und das muss man
zurückerobern können sagt man hier und
deswegen ist der Auftritt glaube ich
auch im amerikanischen Kongress heute
abend extrem wichtig erinnert ein Stück
weit an den 26 dezember 1941 als Winston
Churchill der britische Premierminister
hier war die moralische Verantwortung
Amerikas appelliert hat hier im Kongress
und ähnliches wird selenski auch heute
abend tun weil er die Hoffnung hat dass
erstens dieses Hilfspaket von 45
Milliarden noch verabschiedet wird und
zweitens auch im nächsten Jahr bei
zweitem nachdenken auch in den Reihen
der Republikaner genug Unterstützer sind
um weiterhin der Ukraine in diesem Krieg
beizustehen wenn man vielleicht mal zwei
Fragen hier von unseren Usern Equinox
fragt via Youtube wie schnell kann denn
dieses patriot-system überhaupt
geliefert werden und einsatzfähig sein
das kann man sicherlich nicht aus der
Entfernung auf den Tag bezeichnen und
betiteln aber kann man sagen es muss
schnell gehen die Bevölkerung wartet
darauf das ist auch ein Zeichen heute
ja das System das wissen wir aus einem
Gespräch hier mit engen Beratern von Joe
Biden das steht eigentlich schon zur
Verfügung allerdings müssen natürlich
ukrainisches Personal also Soldaten an
diesem patriot-system trainiert werden
das wird geschehen es wird nicht genau
gesagt wo das passiert ob in Deutschland
beispielsweise auf einem US-Stützpunkt
oder anderswo und wenn das geschehen ist
diese Einweisung dieses trainieren dann
wird das Petrus System in die Ukraine
verbracht und dort ausschließlich von
ukrainischen Soldaten bedient eben nicht
von amerikanischen Wald man achtet
weiterhin darauf dass man nicht direkt
in diesen Krieg hineingezogen wird dazu
passen die zweite Frage von Sasu Brunnen
wir facebook wird mit dieser Lieferung
des Patrick Systems die nächste
Eskalationsstufe gezündet oder will man
genau das vermeiden wenn man es
überhaupt kann
ja ich glaube es soll ein Signal schon
nach Moskau sein man will ein wirksames
Abwehrsystem an die Ukraine geben um
eben die großen Städte zu schützen denn
was wir in den letzten Tagen und Wochen
ja erlebt haben ist ein massiver
Angriffskrieg zerstörungskrieg gegen
große Städte in der Ukraine willkürliche
Ziele werden ausgesucht also
Zivilisten getroffen große zivile
Einrichtungen die Infrastruktur die
geschützt werden soll so wollen dass die
Amerikaner speziell das Stromsystem die
Wasserversorgung und ähnliches und
deswegen das klare Signal nach Moskau
dieses System soll dazu beitragen dass
die Ukraine in den nächsten Monaten
nicht nur diesen Winter übersteht
sondern auch in der Lage ist eben eine
mögliche Verhandlungsposition für
irgendwann im nächsten Jahr wenn Putin
bereit wäre auch zu verhandeln deutlich
zu verbessern
abschließend muss ich ihn Anbetracht
dieser Bilder und der Tatsache dass sie
Lenz gegen Washington ist Brüssel heute
fragen lassen obwohl es um einen Krieg
und eine Sicherheit Frage in Europa geht
das Brüssel das Europa nicht der erste
Ansprechpartner ist
ja das wird hier öffentlich natürlich
niemand sagen auch das Weiße Haus übt
keine offene Kritik an der
Bundesregierung oder an den europäischen
Partnern im Gegenteil man sagt man steht
ganz dicht und geschlossen zusammen aber
im Hintergrundgesprächen hören wir
natürlich schon auch Kritik ein Stück
weit Zweifel wie ernst das denn alles
gemeint ist mit der Zeitenwende warum
tun sich die Europäer so schwer
Waffensysteme allen voran auch Panzer zu
liefern die Amerikaner können ihre
Abrams Panzer nicht so einfach liefern
weil die schlicht und ergreifen mit
Kerosin fahren nicht mit Diesel und das
ist der einzige Treibstoff der schnell
zur Verfügung stünde in der Ukraine also
die Amerikaner sind schlichte und
ergreifen die größte Militär macht der
Erde und deswegen fühlen sie sich auch
in der Pflicht und Joe Biden besonders
in der moralischen Verpflichtung der
Ukraine zu helfen denn es geht aus Sicht
Washingtons hier nicht einfach nur um
irgendein Krieg in Europa sondern um die
große Auseinandersetzung sagt Joe Biden
immer zwischen dem Autoritarismus und
den liberalen Demokratie immer
abschließen wir haben noch mal die
Bilder aus einem anderen Blickwinkel
gesehen wie sie lensky vorfährt und
begrüßt wird nur schnell noch der
Ausblick was passiert heute noch wie ist
der Plan für diesen Tag
ja also jetzt wird man sich erstmal
unter vier Augen zusammensetzen im
Weißen Haus danach trifft sich selensky
mit dem Sicherheitskabinett von Joe
Biden Verteidigungsminister Nationaler
Sicherheitsberater und anderen und dann
und gibt es eine Pressekonferenz
ebenfalls im Weißen Haus im e-strom dann
erwarten wir auch die Ankündigung über
weitere Hilfen auch die Patriot
Flugabwehrsysteme und am Abend um 7:30
Uhr abends derzeit hier in Washington
tritt der Kongress zusammen beide Häuser
des Kongresses werden eine Rede von
Volume selenski hören und das soll eben
ein Stück weit befeuern dass man in den
nächsten Tagen noch dieses große hilfs
Paket verabschiedet einmal vielen Dank
für diese Eindrücke und live Kommentare
auswaschen danke
und damit schauen wir auf die andere
Seite der Welt nach Moskau dort hat
Präsident Putin ich habe es vorhin schon
angedeutet heute Stellung bezogen man
muss es so sagen wie dieser Krieg der
nicht so heißen darf offiziell in
Russland aus seiner Sicht verläuft und
laufen wird auch da sehen wir Bilder
eingeblendet auf den ersten Blick war
all das keine Überraschung was er da
heute gesagt hat alle Ziele würden
erreicht sagte Putin vor diesen
Vertretern die wir hier sehen das
russischen
Verteidigungsministeriums alle haben
gebannt gelauscht da gab es kein
Widerwort oder irgendeine
meinungsdiskussion es war eine
Verlautbarung von Putin und ich glaube
das ist die Botschaft dort heute gewesen
er sorgt mit seinen Äußerung für Ordnung
und Klarheit aber auch das kann ja viel
sagen sein und darüber wollen wir reden
mit unserem Korrespondenten in Moskau
hallo Christian Sam
wunderbar passt dass sich Putin
überhaupt nach mehr als 300 Tagen Krieg
zu seinen Zielen äußern muss dass er
keine Erfolgsbilanz verkünden kann
sondern eher Erklärungen liefern muss
was sagt das
ja ich glaube das ist eine Frage der
Sichtweise also das Putin sich noch mal
erklärt und auch für die Russinnen und
Russen und auch noch außen hin kein
Zweifel daran lassen will dass er
absolut davon überzeugt ist dass diese
spezielle Militäroperation sowie der
Krieg hier genannt werden muss dass die
im Erfolg mündet ich glaube da lässt
Putin die Gelegenheit natürlich nicht
aus ähm und was interessant war heute zu
sehen
er hat ja nicht nur gelobt und nicht nur
sozusagen nach vorne blickt und betont
wie viel Geld jetzt noch mal investiert
wird und was alles noch gemacht werden
muss damit die russische Armeen das im
Militär vor Ort besser ausgestattet ist
es gab aber durchaus auch Kritik in der
Vergangenheit die insgesamt natürlich in
Russland nicht so gerne gesehen wird die
öffentlich auch meistens nicht ähm
diskutiert und eingeräumt wird und da
war doch auffällig dass Putin heute auch
betont hat dass die Probleme die es
beispielsweise weil bei der
Mobilisierung gab dass er die erstmal
zugegeben hat dass sie behoben werden
sollen und das ist auch Probleme
natürlich bei der Versorgung gab also
zwar öffentlich an ganz klarer Auftrag
sozusagen ins Aufgabenbuch seines
Verteidigungsministers dass er das
natürlich nicht gerne sieht und dass
diese Schwächen so schnell wie möglich
behoben werden sollen ein Beispiel war
dass er angekündigt hat dass die
Soldaten jetzt alles bekommen sollen was
sie für ihren Kampf brauchen moderne
Waffen gute Ausrüstung und die Frage die
natürlich auf der Hand liegt warum haben
sie es nicht längst
ja das wird Putin sich auch gefragt
haben es war ja immer wieder auch zu
hören dass er möglicherweise von einem
anderen Zustand seiner Armee ausgegangen
ist und dass er eben das öffentlich
jetzt kommentieren muss zeigt dass
dieses Problem im Kreml offenbar
angekommen ist mit dem ganz klaren
Hinweis von ihm heute dass diese
Probleme behoben werden sollen wir hören
mal kurz rein denn in der Tat wie du
hast schon gesagt hast es war von
Maßnahmen die reden auch von Optimierung
wir sprechen gleich weiter und hören
einmal was Putin gesagt hat heute
besteht unsere Aufgabe darin ich hier
notwendige Maßnahmen umzusetzen für die
Erneuerung und die Optimierung
darauf möchte ich Ihre besondere
Aufmerksamkeit lenken die gesamte
Information
der über die nato-kräfte der Mittel die
eingesetzt werden im Laufe der
militärischen sonderoperation
sind uns sehr gut bekannt das alles
liegt Ihnen vor und das alles muss ganz
gründlich analysiert werden genutzt
werden für den Aufbau unserer wie ich
bereits sagte Truppen unserer Armee um
unsere Kampfmöglichkeiten unserer
Truppen zu steigern und auch unsere
heimischen Sicherheitskräfte
da kann man raushören dass er
unzufrieden ist Christian das ist eine
Botschaft nach außen all das was er
gesagt hat er hat von Waffenlieferung
gesprochen von modernen Panzern nicht
Panzern sondern von Raketen und von von
Raketensystemen auch ist das eine
Botschaft die natürlich nach Washington
gerichtet ist aber vor allem auch ans
Land ans Landesinnere an seine Russinnen
und Russen selbst
die Botschaft soll vor allem heißen dass
man keine Schwäche zeigt und dass man
natürlich weiter
voranschreiten will dass man weiter das
Militär unterstützen will wir haben es
eben in dem Motor auch gehört man
versucht natürlich auch Erkenntnisse zu
gewinnen aus dem was man sozusagen an
Waffen des Gegners sammelt und Putin hat
heute auch ganz klar betont noch mal und
das auch nicht zum ersten Mal aber er
hat es heute wieder betont dass ich
Russland massiv bedroht sieht eben durch
die NATO Waffen und das Russland an
diesem Konflikt sowieso keine Schuld
habe sondern dass man in den letzten
Jahren immer versucht habe sozusagen ein
gutes Verhältnis zum besten zu haben
Russland leider nicht gehört worden und
dann ähm sei das ganze ebenso eskaliert
dann habe aber Russland keine Schuld
sondern eben nur die anderen Staaten
also wieder mal sich als Opfer in diesem
Konflikt in diesem Krieg dargestellt
Christian
sein Verteidigungsminister hat davon
gesprochen dass es möglich sei dass auch
die Altersgrenze für Wehrpflichtige
erhöht wird Männer bis 30 sollten
demnach auch eingezogen werden können
wie kommt all das an was bedeutet das
für diesen bisher ja doch oft gesehenen
geäußerten hurra patriotismus ist der
noch aufrecht zu halten wie wird das im
Land gesehen
das ist ganz schwer zu beurteilen weil
für uns als westliche Medien wird es
auch immer schwieriger zu arbeiten und
ein objektives Stimmungsbild hier zu
bekommen beispielsweise wenn wir unsere
Straßenumfragen machen wenn wir mit den
Russinnen und Russen auf der Straße
sprechen da bekommen wir immer weniger
offene antworten weil die Menschen
natürlich Sorge haben sich öffentlich zu
äußern es gibt verschiedene Gesetze wer
die Armee das russische Militär
öffentlich diskretiert läuft Gefahren
dafür bestraft zu werden entweder mit
Geldstrafen oder Gefängnisstrafen als er
will sich keiner wirklich äußern schon
gar nicht ähm einem westlichen Medium
gegenüber insofern ist es oft schwierig
zu beurteilen wie denn das Stimmungsbild
tatsächlich ist aber was wir
beispielsweise gesehen haben nach der
Mobilisierung im Oktober haben ja viele
Russen fluchtartig das Land verlassen
weil sie eben doch Sorge hatten jetzt
auf einmal in diesen Konflikt mit
reingezogen zu werden einige dieser
Menschen dieser vor allem es waren viele
junge sind mittlerweile zurück weil klar
irgendwann geht das Geld aus es geht
natürlich auch die Perspektive
irgendwann vielleicht im Ausland wenn
ich jetzt zum Beispiel in der Türkei
warte oder in Georgien und einfach nicht
weiß wie es vielleicht dort weitergehen
kann und was in der Heimat auch droht
und jetzt ist natürlich wieder ein
bisschen Zeit vergangen es ist da nichts
weiter passiert einige dieser jungen
großen haben dann vielleicht doch noch
keinen Einberufungsbescheid bekommen und
sind zurückgekommen und auch wenn Putin
heute gesagt hat es wird keine weitere
Mobilisierung geben glauben ihm dass
viele Menschen hier nicht weil wenn auch
die Streitkraft der Armee erhöht werden
soll und auch die Kapazitäten dann
fragen sich natürlich viele hier wie das
geschehen kann insofern sind weiter
viele glaube ich sehr sehr skeptisch ob
sie nicht doch vielleicht in diesen
Konflikt hineingezogen werden können und
wie viele Menschen tatsächlich diesen
Kurs unterstützen ist schwer zu sagen es
wird diese Menschen bestimmt sicherlich
noch geben das Fernsehen das
Staatsfernsehen spielt immer noch eine
große Rolle die Propaganda die jeden Tag
dort wiederholt wird setze ich natürlich
in den Köpfen der Menschen auch fest das
hören wir auch bei den Umfragen dass
diese Propaganda Floskeln dann auch
öfter wiederholt werden aber wie groß
sie Unterstützung tatsächlich ist ist
für diesen Kurs den Putin eingeschlagen
hat ist ganz schwer zu beurteilen aber
man sieht und hat hier gehört heute
Putins entschlossen all seine Ziele zu
erreichen in der Ukraine was immer das
heißen mag und wie lange es dauern wird
Christian sem danke auf jeden Fall für
diese Einordnung live aus Moskau danke
dir ciao
schauen wir jetzt mal auf beide Seiten
Washington zum einen Moskau zum anderen
aber auch nicht ohne interessant die
Rolle China's und darüber werden wir
gleich sprechen mit unserem
Militärexperten damit gleich dazu holen
vielleicht vorher noch ein schneller
Blick auf das was dieses Patrick System
wovon vorhin in Washington die Rede war
überhaupt kann
das patriot-system eins der modernsten
Flugabwehrsysteme der Welt von den USA
konzipiert wurde es in den 80er Jahren
in Dienst gestellt und seitdem immer
weiterentwickelt
seine Aufgabe Flugzeuge Raketen und
Marschflugkörper abwehren sprich in der
Luft zerstören aus mobilen
startstationen werden längfluhkörper
abgefeuert auf Ziele die das
dazugehörige Radar zuvor als feindlich
identifiziert hat 50 Ziele kann das
patrealsystem gleichzeitig überwachen 5
gleichzeitig aktiv bekämpfen die
Reichweite abhängig vom eingesetzten
lenkflowkörper bis zu 100 km in die
Ferne und etwa 30 km in die Höhe
so holen wir Zürich dazu wir sehen ihn
schon von der Militärakademie an der ETH
der eidgenössischen Technischen
Hochschule Markus Kolb schönen guten
Abend schön dass sie Zeit für uns haben
guten Abend grüße sie wir haben es
gerade gesehen fangen wir damit an wie
gesehen Patriot wie wichtig ist dieses
System für die Ukraine
ja es ist natürlich ein symbolischer Akt
weil der Patriots mit Abstand eines der
leistungsfähigsten Abwehrsysteme
überhaupt ist also für für die Abwehr
von Marschflugkörpern von Michael ist
auch von Drohnen und ähm das zeigt
natürlich dass die weder die Ukraine
noch die Unterstützer der Ukraine sich
abfinden werden mit der verbrecherischen
russischen Krieg Führung die ja in
letzter Zeit darauf gesetzt hat eben mit
solchen
marschallerne Infrastruktur und die
Energieinfrastruktur anzugreifen das ist
also schon ein Zeichen dass man sich von
Russland in denen es ihnen nicht
beeindrucken lässt und dass man die
Ukraine auch entsprechend ausstattet um
diese Angriffe zu werden eine Frage
kommt von Chris whats via Youtube ob
dieses Patrick System überhaupt gegen
diese kleinen Drohnen aus dem Iran
effektiv sind
ja also so klein sind die Drohnen nicht
also sie meinen die Shahid 136 doch doch
also die radareinheit kann die schon
erkennen und auch entsprechend abfeuern
die Frage ist jetzt ob sie das Patriot
unbedingt dagegen einsetzen würden weil
das das wäre so von Kosten Nutzen
Vergleich her eine relativ teure Art und
Weise Drohnen zu bekämpfen wenn sie
jetzt aber die Verhütung 136 anschauen
die ist ja erstens relativ laut und
zweitens fliegt sie auch relativ langsam
also da brauchen Sie nicht unbedingt das
Patriot und die abzufahren alles in
allem ist dieses Patrick System für den
momentan Verlauf dieses Krieges in
diesem Winter der Zeit ein gamechanger
also es ist sicher eine eine Ergänzung
der derzeitigen ukrainischen Luftabwehr
aber ein gamechanger in dem Sinn ist es
nicht weil es es verbessert natürlich
die die Verteidigung vor allem der
zivilen Infrastruktur aber von
gamechanger kann man erst sprechen wenn
tatsächlich in diesem Winter oder
wahrscheinlicher im nächsten Frühjahr
ähm die nächste Initiative der Ukraine
los geht und dann wäre die Frage was
werden dann für Waffensysteme geliefert
also im Moment ist es denke ich eher ein
ein symbolischer Akt der auch klar das
Commitment zeigt der USA und ihrer
westlichen Partner die Ukraine weiter zu
unterstützen es ist ein guter und
wichtiger Schritt man muss aber auch
sagen dieses Paket enthält natürlich
mehr als nur das Patriot und das das ist
eigentlich so die Richtung ähm sie haben
gerade gesagt und MRT wir sind zum einen
Gang 2 Milliarden 1,8 Milliarden groß
ungefähr dieses Paket da ist eine Menge
drin das ist weiß Gott nicht nur dieses
Patrick System unter anderem geht es
auch um ein jdam Waffentyp klingt
erstmal viel sagend was genau steckt
dahinter und inwieweit ist das wichtig
zu wissen
ja das ist ein ganz interessanter
Waffentyp man kann sich das vorstellen
ein bisschen wie ein ikea-bausatz also
die Idee ist
Präzisionswaffen sind ja schwierig
herzustellen und auch teuer also nimmt
man einfach sogenannte dumme Bomben also
einfache explosiv Körper und schraubt an
die ein Heck und ein GPS leitgerät dran
und damit hat man aus einer dummen Bombe
mit relativ wenig Einsatz und vor allem
sehr schnell eine präzisionswaffe
gemacht die hat eine Reichweite von
ungefähr 30 km ähm das heißt also es ist
eher für den für den nahe Einsatz
geeignet und so wie sie konzipiert ist
jetzt vor allem von Trägersystem aus der
Luft abgeschossen
das ist interessant weil die Ukraine
damit in die in die Lage versetzt wird
eigentlich ein Großteil ihrer Munition
zu konvertieren in in recht billiger und
schneller Weise in Präzisionswaffen das
heißt also sie brauchen jetzt nicht mehr
so lange und warten bis sie bis sie
Nachschub zum Beispiel für die
heimatsysteme haben sie brauchen nicht
mehr teure Präzisionsraketen einsetzen
sondern dass das verändert dann schon
die die lokalen Realitäten denke ich was
man aber auch sehen muss gerade an die
Adresse derer sage ich dass die in
letzter Zeit immer wieder von sogenannte
Munitionsmangel gesprochen haben dieses
Paket ist vor allem voll mit Artillerie
und mit Artillerie Munition und man muss
eines ganz klar sehen was im Westen
derzeit passiert ist die die westlichen
Rüstungsindustrie werden angeworfen um
entsprechend nach zu produzieren und das
ist ein Effekt den man langfristig nicht
unterschätzen darf weil bisher für
Russland ja den Krieg aus seinen
Reserven und die große Frage die sich ab
nächstem Jahr stellen wird ist wie
leistungsfähig sind die jeweiligen
Rüstungsindustrie das heißt was passiert
wenn die Lage ein Mann leer sind dann
stellt sich nämlich die Frage wer kann
logistisch länger durchhalten und wer
kann mehr und besser produzieren und
dann natürlich auch mit der Frage
sozusagen es muss Menschen geben die das
machen und die wollen müssen auch
gewollt gewillt sein dass irgendwie zu
machen aber genau dazu was sie gerade
sagen weil ich fass mal ein paar Fragen
zusammen was wäre denn so ein
gamechanger im Krieg sie haben es schon
angedeutet aber vielleicht noch mal ein
bisschen expliziter und auch die Frage
wer Youtube von von aige ob deutsche
Panzerlieferungen Leopard Marder Alter
das was immer schon wieder mal
diskutiert wird und im Raum steht ob das
für diesen Winter Kriegs entscheidend
sein könnten
also gamechanger die die zweite Frage
beantwortet ist eigentlich schon wenn
die Ukraine die Russen mit Gewalt aus
ihrem Staatsgebiet herauswerfen will
dann braucht sie offensivmittel und das
primäre offensiv Mittel sind nun mal
Kampfpanzer und es gibt weder technische
noch politische Gründe diese Kampfpanzer
nicht zu liefern es gibt nur einen
einzigen Grund nämlich wenn sie in
Deutschland anschauen die Weigerung des
deutschen Bundeskanzlers ist zu tun die
Amerikaner haben mehrfach signalisiert
dass Sie nichts dagegen haben auch
dieser Einwand mit dem sogenannten
Alleingang zählt nicht mehr also das das
hat nun wirklich nur noch politische
oder vielleicht emotionale Gründe und
ich ich vermute auch in falsches
russlandbild aber wenn sie schon in
welche Phase kommen wir jetzt hinein in
den Krieg wir kommen in eine Phase
hinein in der die Ukraine die Initiative
hat und sie ausnutzen muss
spätestens im Frühjahr 23 denn sie hat
nicht so viele Zeitfenster in denen Sie
diese Offensive führen kann und dafür
braucht sie offensiv Mittel und wenn Sie
nun die Lager voll haben mit Gerät dass
sie ohnehin nicht brauchen
bzw dass sie relativ einfach liefern
könnten dann stellt sich wirklich
langsam aus deutscher sich die Frage
warum tun sie es nicht in wie gesagt
abholen Baltikum sieht das völlig anders
die Frage dazu deswegen habe ich vorhin
ja auch schon mal unterbrochen an der
Stelle aber ich halte es für wichtig
klar Washington Brüssel liefern und wir
sehen das gerade heute ich habe es
eingangs gesagt das ist ein Tag an dem
große Weichen gestellt werden aber auch
Moskau tut es ja und hat heute mit dem
was Putin gesagt hat sehr
unmissverständlich zu verstehen gegeben
dass man gewillt ist an allen Zielen
fest zu halten kostet es was es wolle
das ist etwas wo hinterher nicht zurück
kann ohne Gesichtsverlust und das ist ja
das was bei Verhandlungen gilt immer
auch zurücksichtigen
wie kann ein Kompromiss aussehen wie
kann eine Lösung aussehen in diesem
Konflikt welche Perspektive gibt es
überhaupt wird dort jetzt aufgerüstet
werden da jetzt ein Ost-West-Konflikt in
der Uhr in den in der Ukraine
ausgetragen mit mehr Waffen mit mehr
Munition mit mehr atillerie auf Kosten
der Bevölkerung
[Musik]
ich muss das ein bisschen aufgliedern
also zunächst mal hält Putin sicher an
seinem ideologischen narrativfest er
würde jetzt quasi Krieg gegen die NATO
führen ja also nach dem Motto eigentlich
hätte er diesen Krieg in drei Tagen
schon gewonnen gehabt aber dummerweise
ist dann die ganze NATO auf ihn
losgegangen und jetzt muss er sich
leider gegen die ganze NATO wären es
gibt übrigens auch in Deutschland und
die besten nicht wenige Kreml
Propagandisten und selbst ernannte
Experten die dieses narrativ verbreiten
ich muss dann immer ein bisschen
schmunzeln und sagen wenn wirklich die
NATO hier eingreifen würde mit ihrem
gesamten Material zu Land zu Wasser und
zu Luft dann wäre dieser Krieg in zwei
Tagen vorbei dann gäbe es keine
russische schwarz mehr Flotte mehr und
dann müssen wir uns über vieles gar
nicht mehr unterhalten also zunächst mal
das das ist nicht so dass sie irgendein
ein Stellvertreter Krieg der NATO
stattfindet es ist immer noch eine
russische Aggression gegen die sich die
Ukraine Wert und jeder startet hat nach
Artikel 51 der un-karte das Recht die
Ukraine mit dabei zu unterstützen also
so viel mal zu den Fakten und wenn sie
jetzt schauen näher ist ist Russland
dazu in der Lage also ich meine Russland
ist in diesen Krieg hineingestolpert und
müht sich nun seit 300 einem Tag ab
irgendwelche Kriegsziele zu definieren
oder zumindest irgendetwas zu erreichen
das wird für Putin zunehmend zum Problem
weil irgendwann muss ja mal Resultate
vorweisen und solche Veranstaltungen wie
diese die dienen in Russland nun eben
dazu dass die Führungspersonen
entsprechend Stärke zeigen kann und und
signalisieren kann ich bin hier immer
noch der Chef und ich sage Russland geht
damit versucht er so ein bisschen die
Verantwortung für den Krieg von sich
abzuwälzen und zu sagen ja ich kann ja
nichts dafür wenn die Rüstungsindustrie
nicht liefert oder wenn man ihn
kompetenter Verteidigungsminister das
nicht hinbekommt also solche solche
Veranstaltungen sind eigentlich typisch
für die russische Umgangskultur die
Frage ist dann nur der Unterschied
zwischen russischen Ankündigungen und
russischen Realitäten also Stichwort
Ineffizienz und Korruption in der
leistungsindustrie ich bin da doch recht
skeptisch ob den Russen das gelingt eine
ähnliche Geschwindigkeit und Intensität
der Aufrüstung zu erreichen wie es den
westlichen Industrien demnächst gelingen
wird wir sprechen gleich weiter
vielleicht bei der Gelegenheit wollen
wir noch mal hören was Putin heute
gesagt hat um uns auch da buchstäblich
ein Bild zu machen und Augenzeuge zu
sein denn er hat auch heute wieder von
Atomwaffen gesprochen und Möglichkeiten
die es demnach demnächst geben soll
das Niveau der Bewaffnung auch immer
thomarenbereich ist schon über 91
Prozent weiterhin werden wir die Truppen
umstrukturieren wir haben einen modernen
nuklearen Bereich mit ultra Schall
Avangard der näherer Zukunft werden wir
zum ersten Mal interkontinentale
ballistische raketenformat liefern
Markus Keup ist das atomare selber
Rasseln einmal mehr
nein das sind eigentlich Programme die
ist schon lange gibt also der der
Avantgarde das ist eine Hyperschall
Flughafen der wird schon seit
Jahrzehnten eigentlich
definiert und und entwickelt also die
Ursprünge da die gehen zurück bis in die
70er Jahre die saß
und auch die die andere die ganz Rakete
sind interkontinental Raketen die
ebenfalls schon ich glaube seit 20 17 im
Programm sind und in der Entwicklung
also das ist nicht wirklich irgendwas
neues Russland testet auch immer wieder
und äh Intercontinental Raketen diese
Tests werden entsprechend angekündigt
bei den Generalstäben also sprich wenn
die in Russland das macht wissen die USA
das ähm nein also neu ist das nicht es
kann sein dass das jetzt vielleicht
manche Leute Angst macht weil sie das
einfach nicht wissen aber ähm ich sage
das immer wieder es gibt keine
Änderungen in der nuklearen Bereitschaft
Russlands es gibt nichts was die
Satelliten irgendwie finden die diese
Lage überwachen es gibt keine
Zusammenführung der Sprengköpfe mit den
Trägersystemen also nein es ist nicht
mal selber raus sondern es ist die
Wiederholung des bekannten würde ich
sagen
wir schauen vielleicht noch mal gerade
schnell ins Weiße Haus bei der
Gelegenheit weil es noch mal Bilder gibt
vom Oval Office wenn die Regie das
vorlegen kann und dann können wir
weitersprechen da sehen wir es also
selensky sitzt mit beiden im Oval Office
es ist gemütlich angerichtet sage ich
mal und ich meine es nicht flappig
sondern ich glaube auch das hat alles
Symbolwert was da gemacht wird also man
sitzt bei Kaminfeuer im weihnachtlich
geschmeckten Orgel Office während sie
Lenski dort im olivgrünen Anzug sitzt
auch das ist ja ein Bild mit einer
Aussage Kraft es wird spannend sein zu
beobachten was nachher bei der
Pressekonferenz rauskommt und wie groß
dieses Paket drin ist und auch mit
welchen Worten ist sozusagen geschmückt
wird und wie entschlossen beiden sich
auch Richtung Moskau äußern wird
vielleicht an der Stelle noch mal weiter
auch Putins rechte Hand mit Videos ich
hatte es eingangs gesagt war heute in
Peking unterwegs an diesem großen Tag an
dem vieles passiert bei Staats
Ski china hat ja in letzter Zeit
mehrfach klar gemacht dass es keine Atom
kein atomaren Waffeneinsatz geben darf
keine atomare Bedrohung auch heute wurde
noch mal darauf hingewiesen dass sei
keine Option aber dennoch hat mir den
Eindruck Russland sucht auch in Fernost
den Schulterschluss
ja und und das sagt eigentlich recht
viel aus über die Verhandlungsmacht bzw
die strategische Größe Russlands oder
sagen wir mal das was davon übrig ist
es ist schon so dass China spätestens
seit Mai zunehmend auf Distanz gegangen
ist zu Russland das heißt die Chinesen
Pragmatiker wie sie sind nehmen gerne
die billigen Rohstoffe an das Öl mit
großen discount und genauso auch das Gas
und Flüssigkeit aber sie sagen Putin
auch ganz klar wo die Grenzen sind
konnten ich habe ja schon im März diesen
Jahres gesagt wurde übrigens recht
heftig angefeinde dafür dass Russland
irgendwann zu Chinas billiger kleiner
Tankstelle werden wird und ich denke ähm
wir sehen zunehmend Anzeichen dass ich
die Dinge in diese Richtung entwickeln
ich glaube nicht dass ehrlich gesagt
eine gestellt wie man wird jetzt die ja
nicht mehr zu vergleichen ist mit den
Jahren 2018
Präsident war das also eine Gestalt die
die wirklich nur noch die hässlich
Propaganda auf telegram von sich gibt
nun dahin nach China geschickt wird das
ist kein besonders glaubwürdiges Zeichen
erstens und zweitens sind es eigentlich
die Chinesen die im Moment den Russen
den Tarif durchgeben das heißt was sie
gewillt sind zu akzeptieren und was
nicht kommen wir vielleicht abschließend
und auch da noch einen Kommentar von
emsch Müller via Youtube niemand außer
der Ukraine selbst hat das Recht zu
entscheiden wann es zu Verhandlungen
kommen soll wir haben heute noch nicht
viel von Verhandlungen gehört MRT Wissen
sagt es vorhin es soll keine Direktive
geben aus Washington Richtung Ukraine
wir haben jetzt über Moskau und über
Peking gesprochen ist das heute am Tag
an dem Verhandlungen vorbereitet werden
oder ist es eher ein Tag an dem noch mal
der Bizeps gezückt wird
ich denke es ist ganz sicher kein Anlass
für Verhandlungen es ist auch nicht die
Zeit dafür ich sage das ja immer gerne
an die Adresse derer die sogenannte
Verhandlungen fordern ist sie mögen doch
bitte erstmal definieren über was
verhandelt wird und vor allem über den
Kopf der Ukraine hinweg es gilt ja immer
noch unser schöner völkerrechtlicher
Grundsatz an Nation ist Nation das heißt
also es kommt nicht auf sogenannte
Einflusssphären dieser mancher
kolportiert an auch nicht darauf wie
groß das Land ist sondern es kommt
darauf an dass es hier um eine souveräne
Nation geht und eine souveräne Nation
entscheidet selber ob und inwiefern sie
verhandelt oder aus dem Kriegszustand
aussteigt was heute signalisiert wird
ist ganz klar erstens militärisch die
fortgesetzte Unterstützung und zwar die
Unterstützung derer auf die es ankommt
ich sage immer scherzhaft zum Glück
hängt die Sicherheit Europas nicht von
Deutschland ab sie sehen hier in diesem
Bildern von wem die Sicherheit Europas
abhängt nämlich von den USA also man
kann es noch deutlicher sagen das
einzige dass Europa militärisch
zusammenhält ist das European Command
der Amerikaner das was früher die 7
US-Armee war ohne die wenn sie sich auf
Nationen wie Deutschland verlassen
mussten da wäre in Europa aber relativ
schnell Endstation und diese Gleichung
dass die USA letztlich dass das
militärische Rückgrat für Europa sind
die gilt immer noch und die gilt gerade
wieder heute dessen muss man sich klar
sein klar werden es gibt in Zukunft
vielleicht Nationen wie z.B Polen die ja
im Moment stark aufrüsten oder in
Zukunft auch die neue Ukraine nach
diesem Krieg die dann sicher
frontstaaten sein werden gegenüber einem
feindlichen revanchistischen Russland
und vielleicht wird sich das dann
irgendwann ändern aber der der Support
der USA ist ist entscheidend für die
Durchhaltefähigkeit der Ukraine und ich
denke in diesem Kontext muss man die
Bilder sehen
letzte Frage wenn wir auf all das
schauen was wir heute gesehen haben
welche Bilder es heute gab und die auch
ja ausgesendet werden sollen mitsamt der
Botschaften die dahinter stecken Ihr
persönliches Fazit mit Blick auf das was
West-Ost Fernost heute passiert ist
ja ich denke wir sehen die kommende
Weltordnung des 21 jahrhunderts hier
hier heraufziehen also ich persönlich
rechne damit dass wir nach diesem Krieg
sicherlich keinen freundliches Russland
bekommen werden ist er dann ultra
nationalistisches Russland sein dass ich
im Wesentlichen von der Idee
europäischer Staatlichkeit von der Idee
des Völkerrechts verabschieden wird es
wird ein Staat sein der sich primär nach
Osten ausrichtet China wird das Ganze
pragmatisch sehen das heißt sie nehmen
gerne die Energie Ressourcen werden sich
ansonsten aber nicht auf auf diese
russischen inneren politischen Spielchen
einlassen und ähm der besten wird
natürlich gezwungen sein an der polnisch
weißrussischen und der Ukraine
russischen und weißrussischen Grenze
eine Abwehr zu errichten das heißt an
neuen Eisernen Vorhang mit befestigten
Grenzen ich denke das wird die Realität
für einen Großteil dieses Jahrhunderts
bleiben Markus Korb vielen Dank für
diese Informationen und für diese
Einordnung und Einschätzung danke nach
Zürich danke für diesen Blick
das war schon wieder ZDF heute live an
einem Tag an dem sich ich habe es gesagt
in Washington in Moskau und den Peking
neue Dinge ergeben und wo Weichen
gestellt werden und wir werden alle
Zeuge werden in den nächsten Tagen an
Weihnachten und darüber hinaus was das
alles bewirkt und wie es werden wird mit
diesem Krieg im neuen Jahr danke für
eure Fragen für eure Aufmerksamkeit für
eure Kommentare und bis zum nächsten Mal
macht's gut ciao